SIR.
THANVERY MUCH.
MR. ID VPU
RELATIONS WEREA  SUMMIT CHANGE.D
INATYOU'RE UNAFRAIL OUT
USSIAN LIKE CYBER HACKS AND
INTERFNG AFERENCE IN, WHNO
ST A SIDE-BY-SIDE TO
HITH THE WORATG.MAKE IT CLEA
POINT.
AND EP ON HOW HERESPONDS TO ACTN
H IM WHEN
AND I WHEN GOT ELECTED, BEFORE
WA
D  NOT HE,
INAC ENGAGE INN, THAT A
INV
Y BREACH THAT
I GO.RA AND  DID
I DI
OUTO AL TINTELLIGCEASNGALACTIV
RESPONAITH REGARD TO -I ALWAYS
EATHOU MYSELF VERY
CLEAS  RELATIONSHIP ARE SIA.
WE'RE NOINR CONF.
VE THOSE
INCONSISTENT WITH INTERNATNA
NORMS, NUMON TWH
TOGETHERWE MO DO
THN TERMOF SOME STRATEGIY BE B
WORKED TOGETHER, WE'RE
DO IT.ERE MA AREAS.
THERE IS TALE ABILITY
TOIME.
IK ST WAY TO DE WTHISI HAME H
O HAVE OURSION.
DON'T DOUBT THAT I'LLY STRAIGHV
HOW TH MEETI TURNED OU
PEURD
DON'T WANT
HANDS, -- WHO TA S
HES ABOUWHAT I THIHENG
ABOUT.
THAT IS HOW I'M GO HANDLE
>> Y>> I'MORI MAY HAVE, IF I DOH
THE RIGHT WAY.
JENNIFER JACOB, BLOOMBERG.
NK YOU, SIR.
ON CHINA, -- SORRY, CHINA ISY W
WIANG ANA SEA DESPIT
ALLIES,
LANGUAGE IN CATIONES HAVE SOME
ED I.AW A DRAFT AND
GH. IT AS TOUGH.E ISN'T RY
DISAPPOIEDND WHAT  WHY I'T
YOCOULD YOU  TINNS
FROM CHINA.
>> LTIT THERE
WAS NOENCHINA.THIS T MENTION
OF
CALLED O H RIGHTS BRUCES
INANG AND HONG KA NMS
COMPETITION AND  I
NOW HOW TO DAT.REE TOACTIONS AG
INDUSTRIES BECAUSE TIT IS E
EARLIER, I FEERY STRY,
OP THAWE HAV
LTTHE
BELT AND RD INITIATIVETO
BACKTER.EY'VE AGREED TNDDERWAY
OF THAD AT
TOGETHER A CMIT
AND COME UWI    THAT.
AND THIRY O GHARDS
CLIMATE FRIENDLYRATO THE BT
E WE'RGOING
, I THINK LETHWAY, ITOSOD ROSAI
WITH CE,
DLY CHGINTURY. DEMOCRAN COMPETE
THINK  ACT  PULL GEDEMOCRACIES G
COARE N.AN A O ARS FROANSA STEPN
TOO.INCED THAT IS CORRECT NOW,
I SHOULDN'SANOW.ST BECAUSE OF M
SE.
SEJUAIGHTFORWARD DEALING
WHERE WEATE AND WE'LL RESPON
ACTIONS THATT.
FOR EXAMPLE WEALT  IS ONE THIN
WHURGRICULTURE
POLICY MAKES SENSE AND  BY TH Y
US
CO
YOU ALL OF ME SECR
NO, NO
MARYOSAYING
YOU ARE SATISFIED WITH WHAT CAMS
ON CHINA.
>>HES PLENINA AN ALWAYS SOMETHI
MPATBUT I'M SATISFIED.REUTERS.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.
W  OE E COMMUNIQUEAD
ERYTHING FROM HUMATSORS
IWAN
NSHINK CHINA HAS T
ACT MORENSS OF
INL HUN
RIGHTS AND
E
BOARD.
AND I THINK TH FOR
E ONE OFHE I
I HAVE NOT REACHED ACAN'TCE LABT
- FROM T PLACE OF A RF IN THE E
-19, OR WHETHE EXPERT  AWR A
LARAIMPORTANT TOW
E  H
ICWE HAVTOE CE. ANOTHER TRK OF R
TH HTO WE'AT
THE D T
TOGETHER AN INTERNATBASIS
UPONCHHAVE INWI WSPARENCY ACCOU
THEY>> TO ANSWER THAT QUESTI,
THERE IS N WITHOUT SELF-SERVINLT
WAS THE NEED FORS  B PROTECT
ECON TO IT THAOTHER STRUGGLINGNO
AND
WED CA
NATIONASK THAT T.YING T AY.
D HEALTH ORGANIZATION JOURNAL,"M
1 BILLION DOE
.HOW WIOUE THAT GAP,
G T22.
IT MIGHT TAKE IG LONGER E.
TATEIS GOING
TO CONTINUE, THERE
2022 GOIN23 TIN A PRO
BUT THAT IS NOT DONE CAREFUL A
PAEM K
AND SAY WHAT I TG THNGS AND E SS
HAVET  YETSO THERE WAS A CLEAR W
THE WHRLD.OVIDR TAY AT IT UNTIL-
IT IS NOJU T
TO DO FROM A -- HO
IT, FRTA BUT
IT IS ALSO THE CORRECT THING T
TE OWN
RITYN'T BUILD WALL HIGH
KEEP OUTAI
YOU CAN'T DONK THIS IS GOING TOC
THERE MAY BE OTHER GAUPEB COUL
DETECT BE  GETS T
CORO
ON THEIZS ISN.O -- AS N NEED,
BEG  V
IN FACT -- NOTY THAT, WE'V
BENG IN G, WHICHADE D MOST OF LD
IT, AND THEYOOD ITKNEWM TR, GIGA
EFIT IS ONE THIN S
X, Y NUMBER OFACCINETHE PEOPLE
SO.
W THE
ABILFOR COUNTRIES TO
THEIR VACCINES.
INS THPAAT
THEY D'TTHCA
O DOHE
FAUTA LOT GOING O NOO PRS TO PR.
>> IT.NOI'
ALEXANDE NBC THANK YOUMUCH.
AB AND YOUR K, AS YOU'RE
SLAPPING SANIO O FOR
YEARS FOR ITS MALICTIVITIES D R.
SO WHAT SPECIFICALLY WILL YOU
DIFF CHANGE VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S BEOR THERE IS
YO SOMEONE'S --
THAT IN'T DISSUA H
TO KEEP GOING.
DEALING THG WITH- LEMMAS LET'S O
COVID D DEALINNLY
E UNITED STATES BUT EUROPET
LAANMIDDLEANSO IS A LOT ING ON
FOR EXAMPLE, I
BE O PROV-- FD
ST AND ECOC MEAN VITAL ASSISTAN
OU
I THINK I'TO TRY VERY HARD TO --
NEGOTIATING
IN PUBC T ME
ITS WAY.
WHICH AR--E BELIEV
CO.E ALSO BITTE
SOME REA
AVOUBL THEOF
WIT NG ORDER IN THE REGION
YOU CAN'HA
WITHOUT OVBA
HOPEFUL THAIO WHERE
WE COULD SE TH
PEOPLE IN FOR EXE, IN THAT CONS
I
SAME REASON, THEAMRE
WHE HASN'T SP TTH H
DONE TTHIS POINT. S VL
I'ET INT
I'VE GOTO SIT DOWWITH HIM AND E
K AFTER TH.
CONE.D THAT RUSSI
ER
THIS MEETING COMG UP.SO AOU THAV
CR AGAINST RTHAT IK THE PE
RIE
BEING HARBORED IN THUNITED
STATES, I' TG THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
I WAS FLYING HERE,
.I INTERESS.ALVEK YOU.
BUT PRETEND I DIDN A
T MECK.
KME ERA STEUM WHE
ABTHUR